Paul is starting off this hour in New
York City hi Paul how are you good day
thanks for taking my call sure man
what's up KITT along leave my wife we're
trying to figure out our budget the
problem we're having is we're
self-employed and we don't know exactly
how much money is coming in every month
right so our budget we're trying to
figure out our budget and rather in
typical time given out okay
well let's let's stop first thing is you
need to do a unique budget each and
every month everyone does so you do
March's money in March and June's money
in June okay we don't have a template
that works throughout the year some
things repeat obviously the house
payments going to be exactly the same
and other thing I'm going to be exactly
the same but we're going to we're going
to do a unique budget for each month the
second thing is this how long have you
been self-employed about 10 years no
good okay and does she work outside the
business no okay so the entire income is
the self-employed income yes that's okay
what's your low average month your
average - a little low month would be
probably that 10,000 take-home pay well
we did that problem is we don't take a
paycheck or an LLC so we just take goals
out of the let your income okay but you
have to set taxes aside right yeah we do
that at the end of the year we just pay
our estimated taxes throughout the year
yeah so you have to set the money aside
for estimated taxes and so is the ten
thousand after estimated taxes or before
if you're pulling money out of the LLC
you should put you should take a portion
of that money and set it aside for
estimated and you should take the rest
of it home yes if we pay everything
through to business so that's where
we're having a problem is we don't they
say as money comes in
going right back out pay everything you
mean you pay the estimators to the
business you know by your grocery as a
business that while we power mortgage
all over his networks and yeah that
doesn't work you can't do that your your
mortgage is not a deductible business
expense our our accounting policy we
were trying to take a paycheck but our
accountants just telling us that we are
not allowed to take a paycheck through
an LLC you need a new accountant this
guy's an idiot he's got you paying your
mortgage out of your LLC and telling you
you can't take a paycheck from an LLC of
course you can I take one every month
from my LLC okay and everybody else does
too by the way except people who don't
make enough in the LLC to draw a
paycheck out of it but I mean it's just
a company and you don't need to be
paying personal bills out of your
business account so let's go back at
stepper to step number one is a separate
business account that all the income
from the business goes into that account
and only business expenses come out of
that account what's left in that account
is called profit each month let's
pretend that's $10,000 okay okay when
you take the $10,000 and write that
check out of that business you don't
have to have it as a formal paycheck
with formal withholding but if you're
smart you will set the money aside for
estimated taxes and so you set aside you
know 25% let's say so he says that two
three thousand bucks we'll call it three
thousand bucks to set aside out of ten
thousand for taxes because that's about
how much they'll be on that and then
because you've got to conclude
self-employment tax as well as income
tax as well as New York tax so three
grand out of ten thousand so you take
home seven thousand does that sound
right yes okay now you set the three
thousand aside on a separate account so
you've got the money to pay your
estimated with your new accountant
okay then from there through
few accountants you know you need
another one on the so then the next step
is how to answer your question which is
how do we live on an irregular income so
we know nine times out of ten ninety
five times out of 100 whatever it is
you're going to bring home seven grand
because ten thousands you're low average
it'd be really bad month if you didn't
have that much right yeah so highly
unusual so you can run a budget on that
seven thousand a regular budget that
much is predictable but most months you
make more than that so how do we
allocate that money in advance well
let's do a regular budget with seven
thousand dollars pay the regular bills
so pay the house payment the food the
lights of water and you spend that seven
thousand each and every month on paper
before the month begins then other
things that you should do could do or
want to do that didn't make the seven
thousand dollar budget make a list of
those things like pay extra on that safe
for vacation whatever it is you're doing
okay
and you make a list of those a good long
list and you look at that list and say
if we make one dollar more than seven
thousand where are we going to put that
dollar what's the most important thing
on this list and you put a one beside
that and then you ask yourself if we can
do one more thing after this number one
item what do we do and you put a two
beside that if we can do one more thing
after this item you put a three beside
that and so on and then you rewrite that
list in order of most important to least
important things above your seven
thousand dollar budget then when you
make money above the seven thousand you
spend it right down that list so your
that money is also spent on paper before
the month begins you have what's called
a prioritized spending plan or an
irregular income budget at that point
and you can do that with the every
dollar budget all you're doing is going
back in and resetting it as you know
what your numbers are and you can apply
it that way and I'll send you a copy do
you have a copy of the book the Total
Money Makeover yesterday okay in the
back of that book is a set of budgeting
forms one of the forms I believe it's
number eight or something like that is
called the irregular income
budget for him and it will teach you
reteach you what I just taught you again
so you can go back and review that but
you need to separate your business
expenses from your household expenses
they need to be in separate accounts you
cannot do proper analysis on your
business till it's profitable
what's fun what's not when it's all
jumbled up with your grocery money you
know the proper I ie part of doing
accounting in business as you can tell
what's going on with your business
you're reading the tea leaves of your
business you see which products are
working in services are working or
you're making your profits and what
items are losing money and we don't want
to do that and I want to continue that
product line and you can't know all of
that if it's mixed up with bananas and
pears and loads of bread because your
grocery budget or your mortgage budget
isn't tied up in your same account
that's just disastrously bad bookkeeping
and number one reason small business
fail cash flow problems its bookkeeping
in taxes and debt get all fall under the
heading of cashflow problems so you
don't want any one of those three
problems it's the number one thing puts
people out of business you've made it 10
years you're doing good you're making
good money let's just clean this up
thank you Paul this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]